president Trump startled some lawmakers
when he invited the top two Democrats in
Congress to the Oval Office and told
them he would shut down the government
if he doesn't get funding for his
promised border wall president allowed
cameras to capture a 17 minute argument
with Senator Chuck Schumer and
congresswoman Nancy Pelosi we came in
here in good faith and and and we're
entering into a this kind of a
discussion in the public is know ain't
nobody transparency we Jiang is at the
White House the scene of the fracas he's
a good morning good morning John the
dramatic display diverted attention away
from president Trump's frantic search
for a new chief of staff and his
potential legal troubles but it also
gave us a sneak peek into what may be to
come in the new year with a Democratic
controlled house dividing Congress will
you have walls junkets effectively you
don't have boils it is not effective
yeah
public bickering over president Trump's
proposed border wall ended with a
defiant declaration in the Oval Office I
am proud to shut down the government for
border security Chuck so I will take the
mantle I will be the one to shut it up
the president made clear to Democratic
leaders Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi
he is not budging on his mission to get
funding for the wall in a spending bill
mr. Trump wants five billion dollars to
build the wall but they are urging him
to support legislation that offers 1.3
billion for fencing and other security
measures the experts say you can do
border security without a wall which is
wasteful and doesn't solve the problem
it totally solves the problem and it's
very important this is spiraled
after the showdown president Trump stood
by his offer to own a partial government
shutdown and downplayed the wild
exchange I think was a very friendly
meeting the Democrats had a different
take this Trump shut down this temper
tantrum that he seems to throw will not
get him his wall and it'll hurt a lot of
people in a private meeting back on
Capitol Hill Pelosi told colleagues it
goes to show you you get into a tinkle
contest with a skunk
you get tinkle all over you and it's
like a manhood thing for him as if
manhood could ever be associated with
him this wall thing if Congress does not
make a deal by December 21st about a
fourth of the government would close
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
magic things happen at Christmas and
that's what I'm counting on Schumer and
Pelosi offered two alternatives to keep
the government open with short-term
funding Pelosi who is poised to be House
Speaker said President Trump called her
after the meeting but did not say if
he's ready to compromise on cash for his
wall Norah if the government does
shutdown it would be for the second time
this year all right we should thank you
you know it looks like they can't do the
basic thing which is keep the lights on
but there is a little bit of news for
people who think the government is
completely without capability there is a
farm bill that's going through the
Senate and criminal justice reform which
are proceeding with bipartisan support
so the whole thing hasn't broken down
and just a reminder the president
controls and his party controls Congress
it's all Republican control at this
current point right they could solve
this shutdown thing pretty easily I
don't know how that public conversation
was good for anybody to see on either
side and I felt very uncomfortable
watching it yeah so did Mike Pence yes
yeah my pencil here someone said that he
looked like the Elf on the Shelf sitting
there